oh it's so big and moving so fast what
are you what are you Oh
it's poop bombs shoot poop bombs that's
really I'm gonna fight you
huh you want to go bruh hey your slice
slicing you're stupid oh god that
doesn't look good
can't see a Gersh Dern ting I wouldn't
even know if I was passing right by a
fragment oh it's a frag pant okay
oh good steam off I can make it Karen
I've always loved you oh I can't make it
oh uh breach okay good
hello supermoon I love blood-borne okay
back down in it it is blueprint acquired
po-boys thanks Karen I can make that I
can make that hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica I just discovered that I can
make a seamoth a one-person submersible
which means that I only need a Power
Cell which i think is two batteries
glass lubricant which I have plenty of
like my one talent in life is lubing up
the world so I should be able to do this
this is actually amazing I'm making
progress in the game how how astounding
oh can i scan these pygmy think are you
doing run away from me
okay good that did nothing for me I also
tried to get in a fight with these uh
ooh bombers but it didn't go so well for
me but what I do need excuse me sorry oh
is that the one I stabbed
I like stabbed him I stabbed him good
but I'll let him live for now the
majestic pooping creature that he is I
mean honestly
well why is it oh is it
what what I died from ha ha ha ha ha ha
what did I die
Boop what did I have poop poisoning what
the poop that's so stupid I don't know
what happened there well at least I
didn't die forever that was so weird why
did I die I wasn't even aware that I was
close what happened what the poop I
think I life lesson learned never insult
the majestic poop creatures of the sea
they'll come back and get you one way or
another the poop always wins the poop
always wins Oh after running no oh it's
change battery oh that's much better ok
let me go back actually I don't even
think I have warts at the moment ok so I
guess I'm just gonna be riding around
mano-a-mano
I need to get all the courts I can and
I'm pretty sure I actually also need a
little bit of copper - oh it's gonna be
dicey ok so I guess I'm just gonna be
gathering up materials again I don't
know exactly what I lost when I died but
I guess I'll just be going around but
it's so cool because I'll be able to
have a sub maroon I'll be flying or well
I guess I won't be flying but you know
I'll be doing the underwater equivalent
of flying around so I'm pretty sure I
need a lot of quartz some copper if I
can get it which is gonna be dicey
because there seem to be a lot fewer
limestone outcrops and I've seen in the
last games that I played I don't even
know if that's a characteristic of the
new mapping style or just because they
didn't have the cave of terrors and
wonders right outside my door
oh good copper how convenient for me ah
dude you got plenty quartz what else do
I need I'll come back when I'm back in
the base because there's gonna take a
while so BRB
yeah
ah looking ass it's the ridge of wonders
when hopefully the ridge of copper or
head that's not copper was him oh good
copper better be more damn it titanium
they can early will pose like a brewer
well my like goddammit titanium this is
holly balls is it a ball copper good
good for me I wonder why there's so much
limestone on corrupted files what files
what are you talking about files
what do you mean corrupted what are you
talking about corrupted data what a
bunch of ass baloney emergency thanks
Karen Karen I love you baby but this
can't last any longer
hey everybody I'm back so I have
everything except the lubricant and that
is back at my bachelor pad under the sea
so we're just gonna mosey on down over
there seamoth modification season oh I
didn't even know oh what's them what did
it get red oh no not again
okay I thought it was nighttime already
how's about to say even better my escape
pods is about to explode that's a whole
nother story so off to get the lube as
is with every moment in my life it's an
eternal quest to get more Lube so I will
do that I have no other jokes to make
about Lube it's surprising how few jokes
there are to say about copious amounts
of Lube except that I did hear that the
the Oregon it was the funniest thing
they called him y'all Qaeda because it
was your it was the Oregon farmers that
took over the government building and
someone sent them a 55-gallon drum of
Lube when they asked for snags it was uh
it was uh it was very classy
anyway back to the matter at hand which
is building me a submarine
I can finally accomplish my mission yeah
how do I do
oh no oh no do I need do don't I
oh no I need the mobile vehicle BAE I
gosh dang it okay I only need two
titanium ingots oh I think I actually
have that Wow
I'll be able to get it back my children
of whom I know the names of indefinitely
don't have not forgotten huh yeah
oh whoops dammit god dammit I forgot to
do the thing that I was supposed to do
ah
blam I was actually supposed to build
the thing cuz I really hope I remember
their names cuz cuz it's gonna reflect
very poorly on me if I don't
okay release oh haha oh it's so
beautiful
oh gosh it protects Emily equipment I
needed from a theme all OOP okay now let
me climb on okay use vehicle BAE vehicle
seamoth damn it odd took my power self
gosh ding dang it now let's see if I
remember my babies hang on one second
whoa Nelly whoa Nelly
ok ha ha um Geoffrey
Billy Mordecai and Sam wash know Sam was
ma'am ma'am Mason I'm a terrible father
oh the worst oh I can't remember my
children's names
I could hear Karen yelling at me telling
me how in confident I am how I don't
care about my family
Oh Karen I'm sorry I don't care I'm
three hey I've been lost at sea a long
time hang on sir
there's gotta bug me if I don't remember
their names okay I got it I remembered
it I didn't totally look it up Geoffrey
Billy Sam was Marshall Marshall get your
[ __ ] together Marshall stop making me
forget you I never want to forget you my
sweet baby
boys and girl no wait Samwise yeah hey
tans I'd hate to tell you you're better
girl oh okay
Jeffrey Billy samurais Marshall thank
you very much I'll be right back
I need to get some I think I just need
mushrooms cuz I got plenty of copper
last time I get the copper and someone
said that I could just eat creep mine
but I thought it said that it gave like
negative water let me see this
Oh oh that's handy
oh oh that's so handy
oh god it's gone I didn't know who I
thought he was one of those things wait
oh wait hang on a second
I I thought oh god did it say blood boss
I thought it was gonna be a good thing I
thought it was a good uh oh okay I guess
I'm okay I need to get some food come
here shut up shut up shut up good
freakin okay so I need to cook this into
lube and then I got my seamoth and then
we're gonna go on an adventure
hahaha adventure unlike any other yeah
new I thought I cooked a sweet fish
already maybe I didn't
maybe that's different yeah well
whatever I need it get in my belly
okay Lube me up baby oh lewb oh I should
probably stop moaning Lube I probably
stop moaning in general but this one
specifically like of all the words to
moan especially on the Internet in front
of about a million people Lube ain't the
one Lube ain't the one let's just be
honest with me okay all right back up
huh Geoffrey Billy Sam was Marshall how
y'all doing you ready to get to work
oh hell yeah oh where is it please oh
whoa whoa Geoffrey Billy say was
Marshall god damn Oh
oh come here my baby oh oh oh it's so
cool oh it's so cool oh it's
disorienting but it's so cool oh I need
to improve my vocabulary
it's it's it's incredibly bodacious it's
so sickly gnarly bonk sorry sorry boys
sorry boys oh that's so cool okay oh
also don't run into things because I
just damaged my health but that doesn't
matter so there we have it I got a CMOS
so in the next episode um I think what
I'm gonna do is this probably affords me
some protection against the radiation
from the ship so I'm gonna go explore
the ship because I should be able to
make a long-term trip but before I do
that I'm gonna get some food and get
ready to do that so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always Oh
see you in the next video bye bye
is that breath what's up breath huh
you've lives with your weird eyes breath
huh you want to go with me go to Jabra
too bad for you babies by the way I
don't run a bad grade hi baby
lucky God